Have you ever, you know, seen it
happen?
A big corporation suddenly seems
to be all in on a social cause.
Maybe they changed their logo,
rolled out some big new policies
or make statements on issues you
never thought they'd touch.
And it can feel, well, it can
feel pretty significant, right?
Like maybe business is finally
stepping up, getting aligned
with progress, a real partner.
But then maybe you get that
little nagging feeling, is this
genuine?
Or is there something else going
on, something more strategic?
That's such a key question, and
it often leaves you feeling a
bit uncertain, maybe even
confused.
You see these these big shifts
in messaging, these pivots and
how they present themselves.
And you just have to wonder
what's really driving it.
Is that, you know, a real change
of heart, shared values?
Or is it more calculated like
you said?
Exactly.
And that's precisely what we're
diving into today.
We've been reading this really
potent and frankly quite eye
opening document.
It's called the Corporate
Collaborators, how corporations
ally with movements only to
drain them, discard them, and
return to what they've always
been.
And let me tell you, it's not
just some dry academic piece.
It's a pretty stark look at the
power dynamics between, say,
social movements and the
corporate world.
Yeah, our goal today is really
to get past the shiny PR stuff,
you know, to pull out the core
ideas from this document.
We want to understand what's
actually going on when companies
engage with social movements.
What does it mean for the
movements?
And honestly, what does it mean
for us as individuals,
employees, consumers?
We're trying to uncover the the
surprising facts, the real
motivations and the impact which
often gets missed.
Because just to give you a
little preview, the central idea
here is pretty provocative.
It basically argues that this
corporate alliance, you see,
it's not really about shared
values, it's just it's all about
survival, corporate survival,
protecting capital.
That's the bottom line according
to this.
So we're going to try and peel
back the layers on this whole
dynamic.
It's complex, yeah, and maybe a
bit unsettling.
It definitely challenges some
common assumptions, I think,
about corporate responsibility,
social change, all of it.
So yeah, let's unpack it.
OK, let's start where the
document starts, with what it
calls the initial surge.
This idea that Corporations Act
like like adaptive organisms
when a big social movement
really takes off.
Think about recent years, right?
We've seen massive cultural
shifts, protest for racial
justice, huge calls for climate
action.
In those moments, these
movements burst onto the scene
with so much energy they have
demands, justice, inclusion, big
changes.
They feel unstoppable.
And what's really fascinating
from this documents viewpoint is
how corporations react almost
instinctively when these
movements gain steam, get public
attention, demand change,
corporations, well, they rarely
just fight back directly, at
least not initially.
Instead, it seems like they
almost scramble to line up and
declare they're on board.
You see new policies pop up
overnight, new flags being
flown, literally and
figuratively, new codes of
conduct.
Their whole PR machine kicks in,
crafting this image.
You know, we're on the right
side of history.
We're partners with the public.
It's this quick, almost
coordinated embrace.
It really does feel like that
sometimes, like they're all
rushing to show they're aligned.
One company makes a statement,
then boom, boom, boom.
Others follow.
Creates this feeling of a united
front.
But this document throws cold
water on that right away.
It says this partnership, it's
explicitly not about shared
values.
It really questions if
corporations even can act
morally.
And that's where the core
argument really locks in.
It forces you to rethink how you
see corporate social action.
It states pretty bluntly that
corporations aren't moral actors
like people or nonprofits.
They just aren't built that way.
They're described as adaptive
organisms built for one primary
purpose, protect and grow
capital.
Period.
Yeah.
So when a movement gets
powerful, their internal
question isn't what's the right
thing to do based on our values?
Right, so it's not about ethics,
it's a calculation, pure
self-interest.
How does that play out then when
they decide how to respond?
Exactly.
The question becomes what's
safe, or maybe more like what's
going to cost us less.
They weigh the cost of fighting
the movement, you know,
boycotts, bad PR, maybe new
regulations coming down the
Pike, against the cost of just
going along with it.
If fighting back looks riskier
to the bottom line, to their
ability to operate, then
compliance is the safer bet, the
more profitable path.
So that's the path they take.
It's pure cost benefit, not
conviction.
And that leads to this really
vivid analogy the document uses.
I found this really stuck with
me.
It says corporations are like
Afghan leaders during foreign
occupation.
They nod, smile, and mirror
whatever the invader demands,
and they profit while the tide
is high, knowing it will recede.
Wow, that just strips away any
idea of genuine allyship,
doesn't it?
It suggests it's all temporary
appeasement.
It's a.
Powerful metaphor.
Yeah, Stark, even.
Yeah, Because it just dismantles
that illusion of shared purpose
right away.
It points to this really
pragmatic, maybe even cynical
strategy.
Appease, survive, profit while
you can.
Ride the wave.
Because they understand deep
down that the pressure, the
invasion is temporary.
It will recede and that insight
that really sets the stage for
understanding who corporations
really answer to.
It's not the movement.
Which takes us straight into the
next big piece, unmasking
loyalty.
The argument here is if you want
to understand why Companies Act
the way they do, especially
around social issues, you have
to grasp their actual hierarchy
of loyalty.
And it's layered.
And maybe surprisingly for some
customers, we're not at the top.
Not even close, apparently.
Yeah, that really challenges the
old customers King idea, doesn't
it?
This document says
operationally, that's just not
how it works.
Right at the very top, it puts
shareholders, financiers and
regulators unequivocally.
These are the ones providing the
capital, the investment, the
money that makes everything run,
and they provide the legal
framework, the licenses to
operate.
Without them, the corporation
basically ceases to exist or
certainly can't grow.
So their interests absolutely
paramount.
They're the ultimate priority.
So follow the money and follow
the rules.
That makes sense from a purely
business view, but it forces you
to rethink who they're really
trying to keep happy.
It's not necessarily the person
buying the coffee or the car.
Absolutely not primarily.
And then just below that top
tier, you have the executives
and their main job, their
mandate, protect and grow that
capital for the shareholders and
financiers and navigate the
regulators.
They're the guardians of the
capital.
You could say their jobs, their
bonuses depend on it.
OK, so where do customers fit
in?
If they're not king, what are
they?
Because companies talk about
customers all the time.
Well, the document says they're
far down the list.
Important, yes, because they
generate revenue, which feeds
the capital growth.
But their importance is kind of
secondary instrumental.
It serves the higher goal of
satisfying capital providers and
regulators.
And here's the kicker, the
really stark part.
Movements, activists, ideals.
They are not on the list at all
well.
Not on the list at all.
That's blunt.
So if they're not even on the
loyalty list, why bother?
With all the statements, the
campaigns, the DEI initiatives,
why engage?
That's the crucial point about
how they engage, the document
argues.
These external things,
movements, activist, public
opinion, they only matter if
they directly threaten those top
priorities, capital.
And in compliance.
Their influence is purely
leverage.
It's instrumental.
If ignoring a movement risks
profits or market share, or
brings down regulatory heat,
then they'll pay attention.
But it's always transactional.
It's not about believing in the
'cause.
That transactional nature comes
through so clearly in the
examples given, like ESG,
environmental, social,
governance stuff, the document
points out.
When ESG scores got tied to big
investment money, suddenly
everyone was on the ESG train.
It wasn't necessarily a sudden
burst of eco consciousness
driving it, was it?
Not from this perspective, no.
It was a direct response to a
massive financial incentive.
Huge investors started demanding
it.
ESG funds popped up everywhere,
governments pushed it.
If you wanted access to that
capital, better loan terms,
maybe even avoid shareholder
revolt, you had to play the ESG
game.
It became strategically
essential.
Same with the EI, diversity,
equity and inclusion.
When it looked like DEI
compliance could open up new
markets, maybe when government
contracts attract certain
investors, DEI budget suddenly
got huge again.
Not necessarily driven by a deep
moral conviction, but by
tangible market advantages.
Access to capital and pride
campaigns when they were seen as
good PR hitting a growing market
segment without much risk.
Boom, rainbow logos everywhere.
It paints a very clinical
picture.
These aren't moral
breakthroughs, they're
transactions.
I remember that quote from G ES
Jeff Immelt Green makes a screen
that just says it all.
Really.
It's about the financial
benefit, not saving the planet
for its own sake.
Exactly.
And understanding that true
loyalty hierarchy and that
transactional mindset is
absolutely key.
Because if you don't grasp that,
then the way corporate ally ship
seems to just evaporate later
on, it doesn't make sense.
But if you see it as
transactional from the start,
then the fleeting nature, the
hollowness people feel later,
it's perfectly logical.
It was never about shared values
to begin with.
And that fleeting quality leads
right into the next big theme.
The illusion shatters.
The document highlights what it
sees as a huge mistake movements
often make.
They mistake this compliance for
allyship.
They start to believe the
corporate smile is genuine.
The statements are real.
The new policies are permanent
changes.
Right.
And the source really emphasizes
this is a critical and
ultimately pretty painful
misreading of the situation.
It describes this apparent moral
alignment not as real corporate
belief, but as a mask, a
temporary facade, and,
crucially, the loyalty shown.
That smile is totally
conditional.
It's not who they are.
It's a role they play when the
circumstances demand it.
So the mask stays on only as
long as it helps the bottom
line.
That really hammers home the
transactional point.
Again, the cost benefit analysis
never stops running.
Precisely, and the document
explains when those conditions
change, and they always do, the
mask comes off fast.
What kind of changes?
Well, maybe capital gets tight,
less free money floating around
for things deemed extra, or
regulators back off so the
compliance pressure eases.
Or, maybe most visibly,
consumers push back hard against
a particular stance, creating a
financial reason not to be
aligned anymore.
When that happens, the corporate
face changes, sometimes
overnight, and it reveals that
underlying, unchanging focus on
capital.
And that, the source argues, is
why corporate ally Ship so often
feels hollow in hindsight.
All those big slogans, the
flashy campaigns, the
initiatives that felt so
important, they just fade
quickly once the incentives
change.
It's like watching them strike a
movie set after the filming
wraps up.
It's almost like a deliberate
vanishing act.
All that energy the movement
poured in, the protest, the
meetings, the public pressure to
get that corporate buy in.
It's effectively spent, used up.
And then once the pressure's off
or the money incentive shifts,
the company just quietly rolls
back whatever wants embraced.
It really highlights how
temporary these commitments
often are, tying it right back
to that core function.
Protect the capital.
The alley ship was just a tool,
not the goal itself.
And if you need a really clear,
almost textbook example of this
whole cycle in action, the
document points straight at ESG,
Environmental, Social
Governance.
It calls the rise and fall of
ESG the clearest example of this
conditional collaboration
pattern.
It really is a perfect case
study.
For a while there, ESG wasn't
just corporate jargon.
It was like a golden ticket to
investment.
Huge asset managers controlling
trillions basically started
requiring ESG compliance to even
consider investing.
Governments nudged along,
sometimes with subsidies,
sometimes just policy signals.
Investment indexes started
rating companies on ESG.
The entire financial ecosystem
for a period seemed to revolve
around it.
In corporations, being those
adaptive organisms, jumped on
board with incredible speed.
Suddenly every brand was green,
diverse and socially conscious.
You had CEO's giving keynote
speeches about sustainability,
social justice, ethical
governance.
It was this huge wave of
apparent corporate virtue.
But here's where the document
cuts right through that.
It says very clearly, this was
never about saving the planet,
It was about saving access to
money.
ESG in this you wasn't some
moral awakening.
It was a financial lever, a way
to tap into those massive pools
of investment capital.
If you didn't have good ESG
scores, you risked being
excluded by major funds.
It hit your stock price, your
borrowing costs.
That GE quote again, Green makes
us green sums it up perfectly.
It was about the financial
reward derived from appearing
responsible.
But then, almost as fast as it
blew up, the ESG bubble started
to deflate.
The document talks about a
backlash emerging.
You have political pushback
against woke capitalism, maybe
some public fatigue with
perceived virtue signalling.
And critically, investors
started asking harder questions.
Is this ESG stuff actually
boosting returns, or is it just
costing money without clear
financial benefit?
The mood shifted.
And the corporate response?
The quiet rollback companies
that were shouting ESG from the
rooftops started to rebrand away
from ESG.
Those green slogans vantage from
websites and annual reports,
replaced by safe language less
tied to the now potentially
controversial ESG label.
It's a textbook example of the
documents whole thesis.
Shows how fast priorities change
when the money changes.
Proves the commitment was
transactional, not ideological.
A temporary alliance.
And this is where it gets really
crucial, because the ESG story,
it's not presented as someone
off thing.
The document argues this is a
universal pattern, a predictable
cycle that happens with pretty
much every cultural wave that
gets big enough to make
corporations pay attention.
Yeah, the predictability is key.
The cycle it describes is
movement search.
Corporations comply, energy
drains, rollback begins.
It's presented as this
consistent loop.
You see it again and again
across different issues,
different times.
The initial embrace the loud
declarations, then as the
pressure fades or the incentive
shift, this quiet walking back
of commitments.
And it lists some really current
examples of this rollback.
DEI departments, for example, a
few years ago they were booming,
seen as absolutely vital, almost
untouchable.
Now, the source says, many are
being dismantled or having in
their budget slash, often framed
as restructuring or efficiency
gains.
Exactly.
Or think about Pride campaigns.
Remember how they blanketed June
just recently?
Wall to wall rainbows.
Now many have been noticeably
scaled back.
Maybe less prominent displays,
maybe quieter messaging, maybe
some companies just opting out
entirely.
That was quietly, often just
through internal budget shifts
or updated marketing rules.
And remember all those COVID
rules?
Strict mask policies, social
distancing in offices, Vaccine
mandates enforced with real
zeal, Almost all abandoned the
minute the public health crisis
eased, and keeping them became
more costly or inconvenient than
dropping them.
It's amazing.
How fast those vanish.
Despite the initial urgency and
even huge issues like climate
change, the document notes that
corporate enthusiasm for climate
initiatives seems to rise and
fall with subsidies and investor
pressure.
So even something that feels
existentially important still
seems tied to the immediate
financial incentives.
If the carbon credits dry up or
investors look elsewhere, the
corporate commitment can wobble.
All these examples.
Just reinforce that core idea.
Corporations become expert at
absorbing energy when it
benefits them and discarding it
when it does not.
They're incredibly good at
figuring out what's useful now,
good PR, capital access,
avoiding fines, and then just
letting it go when it's not
useful anymore.
The document describes their
view of movements as being like
temporary occupying forces.
Dangerous if you fight them head
on, may be useful if you appease
them, but ultimately irrelevant
when gone.
It's purely transactional,
self-serving, amoral.
Really.
OK to really.
Make this pattern concrete.
Let's dig into some specific
recent examples the document
uses.
Because this isn't just theory,
right?
We're seeing this play out with
major brands.
Absolutely.
The document gives several
detailed case studies.
Let's start with Bud Light and
Anheuser Busch.
That partnership with Dylan
Mulvaney.
The intent seemed clear, signal
they were progressive, reach a
younger, maybe more diverse
audience internally.
It was apparently seen as bold,
a step forward.
But then.
The backlash hit hard, mostly
from their traditional customer
base.
Sales tanked, and that bold move
suddenly look like a huge
misstep.
Precisely the.
Company scrambled.
They distanced itself from the
partnership, put out these kind
of vague statements trying to
calm everyone down.
The marketing people behind the
campaign reportedly reassigned
or sidelined the brand
messaging.
Snap back to traditional safe
branding, sports patriotism, the
usual stuff.
And those internal folks who
pushed for the progressive
campaign, the source says.
They were quietly sidelined.
Their ideas were suddenly
liabilities.
Then there's.
Target remember their big Pride
month displays very visible,
lots of LGBTQ plus themed
products, stuff that, as the
source says, was unthinkable in
rural stores not long ago.
For a moment it felt like a new
normal, like real mainstream
acceptance baked into a major
retailer.
But again.
The backlash came.
Sales dipped in some areas.
There were confrontations in
stores, even threats against
employees.
Target's response?
They scaled back displays move
the Pride merchandise to less
prominent areas off in the back
of the store.
They softened its public
messaging.
And just like Bud Light, the
internal teams or employees who
championed those displays
suddenly no longer celebrated.
Their efforts were quietly
rolled back, conditional support
melting under pressure.
And Starbucks.
Is another interesting one,
maybe more subtle.
For years, it cultivated this
image as a refuge, right?
A third place, where different
identities felt welcome.
Tattoos, piercings, nonbinary
folks.
It felt safe, the document
mentions.
Rural Starbucks often being like
safe islands and hostile
territories created a real sense
of community for some.
But the concern?
Raised is that as inclusivity
perhaps loses its market
advantage or becomes politically
risky in some areas, that
atmosphere is changing.
Policies are reportedly
tightening.
Dress codes, once famously LAX,
are reappearing or being
enforced more strictly.
Bathroom access might be getting
trickier.
And maybe most telling, that
sense of community is eroding.
IS has reported police are
called on homeless people who
linger too long.
That's a big shift from the old
welcoming vibe.
The bubble is shrinking, the
document warns, leaving people
who relied on that safety
feeling exposed.
Even the tech.
Giants, Google, Meta.
They once seemed to almost
embrace internal activism like
it was a sign of being
progressive.
Employee walkouts were
tolerated, maybe even seen as
good.
PRDEI budgets got massive.
It felt like employees had real
influence, but now?
In this era of mass layoffs in
tech, the source points out, DEI
departments are gutted first,
often the 1st to go when cuts
happen.
Those activists who used to
shape policy, now they're seen
more as legal risks or
organizational headaches.
The culture reverts to quiet
control.
The openness to internal dissent
seems to vanish.
Strict communication policies
come in.
A chill sets in and there are
more quick.
Examples Amazon letting worker
activism surge during the
pandemic when they needed
workers badly, only to blacklist
organizers once the storm
passed.
Harley-Davidson flirted with
progressive marketing to reach
new riders, then abandon it to
recapture its traditional base
when it didn't immediately pay
off or upset the old guard.
The pattern in.
Every case is predictable, as
the document puts it.
Use the energy when it's useful,
erase its traces when it's not.
It's a cold, efficient corporate
playbook.
OK, these.
Aren't just abstract corporate
maneuvers.
This is the crucial point.
This rollback has a real human
cost.
It deeply effects people, yes.
This is the often hidden but
devastating part, the
vulnerability of the individual
collaborators.
Think about employees who really
put themselves out there, came
out as LGBTQ plus M or embraced
non binary identities, were
outspoken activists internally.
I often did this believing the
company's messaging, believing
the environment had truly
permanently changed.
They were told they were brave,
maybe even promoted for they
built careers, identities,
professional networks around
this perceived safety and
corporate alignment.
So they took.
A risk trusted the company's
ally ship, and then the rug gets
pulled out from under them.
When the corporate strategy
shifts, that's got to feel like
a profound betrayal.
Exactly when the culture.
Snaps back.
Those individuals are suddenly
left exposed.
The very things one celebrated
now make them too political, too
controversial, or just not a fit
anymore.
Other companies might hesitate
to hire them, seeing them as
troublemakers.
Even people hailed as heroes
during Hashtag Me Too or praised
during the DEI peak can now
carry this stigma of being
difficult.
It's a quiet kind of
blacklisting.
Wow.
So the movement fades and the
people who are most visible in
it are left stranded, marked by
choices.
They cannot take back their
careers, their professional
lives are impacted long term.
And this.
Is where that Afghanistan
analogy comes back.
With such force, the document
repeats it.
Locals who collaborated with
foreign armies believe they were
building a new future.
When the occupiers left, they
were punished, abandoned by the
forces they served and resented
by the culture they tried to
change.
It's a stark comparison, but it
highlights the brutal personal
consequences when that temporary
occupation by a movement ends
and the corporation reverts to
self-interest.
The human fallout is immense,
That human.
Cost really drives home the
documents core argument, the
predictable pattern, the
unchanging corporate nature.
It's not just numbers on a
spreadsheet.
It has real, often painful
consequences for the people
involved.
Which leads us.
To the final section, the
enduring cycle.
This really wraps up the main
thesis.
It just reiterates that
universal loop movement surge,
corporations comply, energy
drains, rollback begins.
It's presented as this
inevitable, almost mechanical
cycle and the end.
Result.
The corporate system snaps back.
It reverts to its original
state, largely unchanged by the
movements temporary pressure.
Maybe a few scraps are left
behind.
A policy fragment here, a slogan
there, But the fundamental
structure remains.
And the collaborators, both the
companies that played along and
the individuals who believed
they're left carrying the
burden.
And why?
Does this happen Because, as the
document argues so forcefully,
corporations ultimately believe
in nothing beyond survival and
growth.
That's it.
That's the core programming.
They aren't moral beings with a
conscience.
They do not serve movements for
the movement's sake.
Their one true purpose is to
serve capital, protect it, grow
it.
Everything else is just a means
to that end.
So the. 2nd, that complying with
a movement stops serving capital
or starts costing too much.
It stops.
And this is key, the document
says.
From the corporation's
viewpoint, this is not betrayal,
it is simply business.
It's not malice, it's just the
logical outcome of their
fundamental nature.
Cold, maybe, but logical from
their perspective.
Yeah, it strips.
Away the emotion we might feel
and presents it as just the
system working as designed.
It's a stark assessment,
definitely challenges how we
might want to see these
Companies Act.
And it leads to this final,
pretty challenging conclusion
about what corporate engagement
really means, right?
So we land at the end of the
corporate collaborators, and the
take away is powerful, maybe
disturbing.
The final argument is that
corporations are, in a way, the
perfect collaborators.
They're masters of mimicry.
They reflect the power facing
them.
They'll mimic loyalty, echo
slogans, even spend money when
they have to.
And they profit from that
pressure while it lasts.
But then.
Just as efficiently, they
discard the movements, the
policies, and the people who
embodied them.
Once that pressure is gone, once
the alignment isn't useful
anymore, they revert back to the
core function, serving money,
not ideals.
It's a stark bottom line.
It brings that.
Afghanistan analogy home one
last time, doesn't it?
In Afghanistan, the occupiers
leave and the collaborators are
haunted.
In America, the movements fade
and the collaborators are
quietly erased.
It's a different kind of racing.
Quieter, maybe, but deeply
impactful for those who believe
the change was real.
And that's how.
The system survives.
According to this view, It's
resilient because it can bend.
It doesn't break, it just
endures.
The temporary invasion of the
movement waits for it to exhaust
itself, lose steam, and then it
swallows the remains, keeps
anything useful, maybe a new
market insight, a profitable
product line sparked by the
movement and discards the rest.
The core drive for capital
untouched.
So the final.
Metaphor, the one that really
lingers, is corporations are not
allies.
They are mirrors that reflect
whatever power stands in front
of them.
When that power is gone, the
mirror shows it's true face
skin.
Wow.
It suggests everything we see,
the ally ship, the shared
values.
It's just a reflection of
external pressure, not an
internal reality.
Take away the pressure and the
reflection changes back to its
default state capital.
So it.
Leaves you thinking, doesn't it?
The next time you see a big
company jump on A cause, change
its colors, make big promises,
what questions should you be
asking yourself about what's
really driving it?
And how does knowing this maybe
change how you think about the
real, lasting impact of social
movements on the corporate
world?
Definitely something to chew on.